La ofensiva contra el dominio del dólar ha
comenzado.
Vaaale, es verdad, para ser justos, cada pocos
años se anuncia el fin del dólar como la
moneda hegemónica a nivel internacional,
su reemplazo por el renminbi chino - llamémosle
Yuan - y el desastre que eso supondrá para
la economía norteamericana.
Y luego nada de nada.
Esto nunca se cumple.
Pero…
Esta vez…
Esta vez las cosas podrían ser diferentes.
El dólar, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik
ha sido la base del sistema financiero y comercial
de todo el mundo, como mínimo, desde los
acuerdos de Breton Woods en 1944.
Han pasado ya prácticamente 8 décadas.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Ahora la urgencia para superar el dominio
del dólar parece cada vez más evidente entre
las dictaduras y las economías emergentes.
Estos países empiezan a tener pavor a las
consecuencias que puede tener su gigantesca
dependencia de los billetes del tío SAM.
Unos por las posibles sanciones a las que
pueden terminar enfrentándose.
En esta línea, las sanciones contra Rusia
y la congelación de los activos de su Banco
Central en Estados Unidos y Europea ha puesto
sobre la mesa la amenaza que el dólar pude
suponer para la “pasta” de los tiranos.
Y, luego, los otros, las economías emergentes
porque temen las consecuencias económicas
que puedan tener las políticas de la Reserva
Federal.
Por ejemplo, la rápida subida de tipos de
interés que se ha producido entre 2022 y
2023.
¿Y por qué digo esto?
Pues porque las empresas de las economías
emergentes para fijar sus precios de exportación
y también para financiarse utilizan fundamentalmente
el dólar.
Y si los tipos suben o el dólar se revaloriza
entonces, entonces pueden tener un problema.
Pues bien, estos son los dos motivos que han
hecho que la ofensiva contra el dólar cobre
nuevo brío.
Por primera vez parece haber una clara voluntad
política para superar el dominio del billete
verde.
C1 ("Estamos viendo una erosión gradual del
dólar.
La imagen que surge es una de un sistema monetario
multipolar”.
Massimiliano Castelli, jefe de estrategia
para los mercados soberanos globales de UBS)
Ahora bien, ¿hasta qué punto está la hegemonía
del dólar en peligro?
¿Será el Yuan su nueva alternativa?
¿Existe alguna divisa que pueda hacer temblar
los cimientos financieros del Tío Sam?
¿Qué consecuencias puede tener esta campaña?
Pues bien, aquí en VisualPolitik vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas.
No adelantéis acontecimientos y prestad mucha
atención.
Después
de
años de especulación da la sensación de
que ahora sí, el Yuan está dando un paso
adelante para acabar con el dominio mundial
del dólar.
Por ejemplo, la cuota del Yuan en la financiación
del comercio mundial se ha más que duplicado
desde la invasión rusa de Ucrania.
¿Por qué?
Pues en gran medida porque Rusia está utilizando
el Yuan para intentar superar las sanciones
occidentales.
Fijaos.
C2 ("No hay duda de que los rusos se han visto
obligados a desdolarizar y también deseuroizar
su comercio [...] Hay pruebas de que Rusia
en particular está haciendo un mayor uso
del yuan, y también está claro que los chinos
y otros están buscando oportunidades para
ampliar el uso del yuan en el acuerdo comercial”.
Brad Setser, ex economista del Departamento
del Tesoro de los Estados Unidos y exasesor
de la Oficina Comercial de Estados Unidos)
Para que os hagáis una idea, el comercio
entre Rusia y China superó los 185 mil millones
de dólares en 2022 y en 2023 quedará atrás
la barrera de los 200 mil millones.
¿Lo más interesante de todo esto?
Que las empresas rusas ya están pagando la
mayoría de sus importaciones chinas en Yuanes.
Y eso no es todo, los intercambios en yuanes
en la Bolsa de Moscú se han disparado y los
bancos excluidos del SWIFT ahora utilizan
el CIPS, el Sistema Chino de Pagos Interbancarios
Transfronterizos.
Y aún más.
Vladímir Putin ha dicho que quiere usar la
moneda china no solo para comercial con China,
sino también como una forma de pago para
el comercio ruso con Asia, África y América
Latina.
De hecho, según ha confirmado el Viceprimer
ministro ruso, Alexander Noval, este país
ya líquida más acuerdos comerciales en yuanes
que en dólares.
Claro que no solo hablamos de Rusia.
Otros países como Arabia Saudí, Bangladés,
India, Argentina, Pakistán, Irak o Bolivia
han empezado - o parecen estar cerca de hacerlo
- a negociar y realizar sus intercambios comerciales
con China directamente en Yuanes.
Y sí es posible que estemos hablando también
de una buena parte del comercio de crudo saudí,
que es, exactamente, lo que explica noticias
como esta.
(9 de diciembre de 2022: Xi pide que el comercio
de petróleo se haga en yuanes en la cumbre
del Golfo en Riad.
Reuters)
En esta misma línea, el 29 de marzo China
y Brasil anunciaron planes concretos para
operar con sus propias monedas y dejar el
dólar de Estados Unidos en sus intercambios
comerciales.
Y aún más, conforme a estos planes, Brasil
permitirá a todos los países sudamericanos
liquidar sus acuerdos comerciales en Yuanes.
Su presidente no ha podido ser más claro.
Atentos.
Incluso una empresa francesa como la petrolera
y energética Total completó a finales de
marzo su primer intercambio de gas natural
licuado en yuanes con la China National Offshore
Oil Corporation.
El intercambio consistió en 65.000 toneladas
de gas natural licuado extraído en Emiratos
Árabes Unidos
Y hablando de Emiratos, la India, parece estar
utilizando los dirhams de Emiratos Árabes
Unidos, incluso, en sus acuerdos con Rusia.
Así que ya lo veis, estamos ante toda una
ofensiva para desbancar al billete verde.
O al menos para reducir su enorme peso internacional.
A ver, estrictamente no es algo nuevo, China
lleva intentando internacionalizar el Yuan
desde la crisis financiera del 2008.
Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os contamos como
a mediados de 2017 nació el “petroyuan”
para comercial petróleo entre Rusia y China,
algo que como acabamos de ver ahora se ha
generalizado a la mayor parte del comercio
entre estos dos países.
Pero sea como sea, el caso es que esta operación
ha cobrado nuevo brío.
Como veis China y otros países quieren evitar
a toda costa que llegado el momento Estados
Unidos pueda congelar sus reservas extranjeras
como ha hecho con Rusia o bloquear sus economías
impidiéndoles el comercio en dólares.
Y eso, eso exactamente lo que ha puesto de
nuevo este tema en la agenda.
La pregunta es: ¿Realmente podría el Yuan
desbancar o al menos competir con el dólar?
¿Decidirán los países árabes pasar del
petrodólar al petroyuan?
¿Nacerá un nuevo mercado offshore de yuanes
para comerciar e invertir con esta divisa
a lo largo y ancho del mundo a la imagen y
semejanza del eurodólar?
T1 (DÓLAR VS YUAN: EL DESENLACE)
Queridos amigos, amigas, el dólar es tan
pero que tan importante en el sistema monetario
internacional que incluso en comparación
hace que el peso económico de Estados Unidos
parezca muy poco relevante.
Fijaos en esta gráfica:
Como veis, mientras que Estados Unidos supone
aproximadamente el 24% del PIB mundial y en
torno al 15% del comercio, el dólar es hegemónico.
Casi el 60% de las reservas extranjeras y
la mitad de toda la financiación internacional
y las transacciones comerciales utilizan esta
divisa.
Si hablamos de finanzas y divisas está claro
que hoy por hoy hablamos sobre todo del dólar.
Y sí, es verdad, puede que lo hayas escuchado:
desde el año 2000, la proporción de las
reservas interna cionales mantenidas en dólares
se ha reducido de aproximadamente un 70% a
menos del 60.
Esto es algo a lo que siempre aluden los catastrofistas
sobre el futuro de los billetes del tío Sam.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento, porque ese
dato, en cierto modo, tiene trampa.
Y es que veréis, tiene trampa primero porque
las reservas internacionales se han multiplicado
por 4, así que hoy la cantidad de reservas
en dólares son muchísimo mayor que nunca
antes.
Y segundo, porque los principales beneficiarios
de esta caída en “cuota de mercado” han
sido, además de la divisa China, las monedas
de Canadá, Australia, Suecia, Corea del Sur
y Singapur.
Pues bien, todos estos países mantienen líneas
de intercambio de dólares con la Reserva
Federal.
Es decir, esto significa que en la práctica
no ya es que estos países sean estrechos
aliados de Estados Unidos, sino que además
sus divisas tienen casi total convertibilidad
con el billete verde.
Y eso es, precisamente, lo que hace que muchas
instituciones no tengan problema en utilizarlas.
En otras palabras que lo miremos por dónde
lo miremos, el dominio del dólar sigue siendo
aplastantemente abrumador.
Es la gran divisa internacional.
Y sí, ya sé lo que muchos queréis que os
diga: que esto está a punto de cambiar por
completo.
Que los chinos les están ganando el pulso
a los norteamericanos.
Que Shanghái vencerá a Wall Street.
Pues…
Lo siento, pero parece difícil que eso ocurra.
Con los datos en la mano no parece que hoy
por hoy el Yuan represente un gran riesgo.
Sí, vale, es prácticamente seguro que la
cuota de mercado del Yuan crecerá en los
próximos años.
Eso es de cajón, China cada vez pesa en la
economía internacional.
Sin embargo, fijaos, en marzo de 2023 y pese
a muchos años de esfuerzo, el yuan apenas
representó el 2,4% de los pagos internacionales
canalizados por el sistema SWIFT, que es el
sistema líder en todo el mundo.
El dólar, por su parte, representó más
del 40% de todas las transacciones.
Pero, para verlo más claramente, echemos
un vistazo al caso, por ejemplo, de Corea
del Sur.
China es de largo su mayor socio comercial:
es su mayor proveedor y, al mismo tiempo,
también su mayor cliente.
Pues bien, el peso del Yuan en los intercambios
de estos dos países ha crecido: paso del
0% antes de 2008 a casi el 6% en 2020.
[Qué evidentemente no es más que eso, un
6%]
Para que os hagáis una idea en las exportaciones
de Corea del Sur a China, que no tienen nada
que ver con Estados Unidos, el dólar sigue
siendo la moneda predominante.
En 2020, el 87% de todas estas operaciones
se seguían haciendo en dólares.
Y respecto a las reservas internacionales,
¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Más de lo mismo.
En este caso, la cuota del billete verde es
del 58% frente a tan solo el 2,7% de su adversario.
Y sí, ya lo hemos dicho, la cuota de mercado
del Yuan en el comercio mundial seguro, seguro
que va a crecer durante los próximos años,
aunque.
Aunque bueno, eso es algo que ya está ocurriendo.
Fijaos.
N2 (La participación de Renminbi en la financiación
del comercio se duplica desde el inicio de
la guerra de Ucrania.
FT)
Sin embargo, una cosa es comerciar en una
divisa y otra muy diferente es estar dispuesto
a guardar tu dinero en esa misma divisa.
Y aquí los Estados Unidos tienen mucha ventaja.
Concretamente, podemos destacar 3 grandes
ventajas.
Primero…
Bueno, son los mercados, amigo
La superpotencia norteamericana tiene los
mercados de capitales más grandes y líquidos
de todo el planeta.
Para los inversores extranjeros es muy fácil
colocar allí sus dólares para sacar rentabilidad
con ellos: acciones, deuda del gobierno, fondos
de todo tipo.
En Estados Unidos puedes colocar, mover o
sacar prácticamente todos los dólares que
quieras sin que eso supongo ningún problema
ni el mercado se venga abajo.
Es demasiado grande.
Esto es algo que no ocurre en China.
¿Y sabéis qué?
En cierto modo, esto nos puede recordar al
caso del Euro.
El Euro es la divisa de un gigantesco bloque
económico y desde su nacimiento ha cobrado
bastante relevancia internacional.
Pero no la suficiente para competir con el
dólar.
Sí, tiene mucho peso en las transacciones
comerciales, pero en el resto de parámetros
esta divisa es mucho más pequeña que el
billete verde.
Y ojo porque en el caso de China no se trata
solo de que los mercados financieros de este
país sean mucho más pequeños, es que la
seguridad jurídica tampoco es equivalente.
Este sería la segunda ventaja.
A ver, se honesto, ¿Con qué estás más
tranquilo?
¿Con dólares en el bolsillo o con Yuanes?
Seguro, seguro, que los que nos estéis viendo
desde América Latina lo tenéis muy claro.
Pues exactamente la misma impresión tienen,
por ejemplo, los países árabes, que no os
quepa la menor duda.
Y luego para colmo, como tercera gran ventaja
para Estados Unidos es que China tiene un
montón de controles de capitales.
Es decir, que no puedes manejar, convertir
o sacar del país el dinero libremente.
Y evidentemente eso hace que difícilmente
te plantees ahorrar en Yuanes.
De hecho, uno de los motivos por los que existen
estos controles de capital es para evitar
que los propios chinos saquen masivamente
sus ahorros del país.
Que es exactamente lo que ocurrió entre los
años 2014 y 2016 cuando se abrió algo la
mano.
¿No lo recordáis?
Pues…
(Las salidas de capitales de China aumentan
hasta un billón de dólares aproximadamente
en 2015.
Bloomberg)
¿La consecuencia?
El gobierno volvió a echar el cierre.
N4(22 diciembre 2017: China endurece la inversión
en el extranjero para reducir los riesgos.
Forbes)
Así que lo siento, pero no, no parece probable
que a la hora de la verdad el Yuan sea una
alternativa real.
Ahora bien, ¿quiere decir todo esto que el
dólar simplemente nunca tendrá rival?
Pues…
Nada más lejos de la realidad.
Atentos.
T2(UNIENDO FUERZAS)
Vale no, no parece que el Yuan chino pueda
ganarle el pulso al dólar.
Se hará más importante y más visible…
Pero no parece la mejor opción para superar
al Tio Sam.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Los adversarios de Estados Unidos lo saben.
Y es aquí dónde surge una jugada, la gran
jugada que tienen en mente.
En marzo de 2023, el Vicepresidente de la
Duma estatal, la cámara de diputados de Rusia,
Alexander Babakov dijo que Rusia está liderando
el desarrollo de nueva moneda para utilizarla
en el comercio transfronterizo de los BRICS.
Ya sabéis, Brasil, Rusia, India, China y
Sudáfrica.
Un grupo que representa más del 40% de la
población mundial y casi un tercio de toda
la economía global.
Poca broma.
Un grupo al que países como Arabia Saudí
e Irán podrían llegar a sumarse.
Pues bien, ¿Qué pasaría si como advertía
el Vicepresidente de la Duma este grupo lanzara
una moneda?
¿Y si esta divisa, además, estuviera respaldado
por oro y otros metales con valor, como las
tierras raras?
Es decir, los BRICS son lo suficientemente
grandes como para arrastrar a otros países
a comerciar con su nueva divisa.
Desde Tailandia a Kazajistán pasando por
media África o América Latina.
Esto quiere decir que fácilmente podría
ser una moneda utilizada para las transacciones
internacionales de países que representen
el 40 o el 50% del PIB Mundial.
Y no solo eso.
Al estar respaldado su valor por activos reales
y carecer de controles de capital, también
podría crearse un mercado financiero que
permitiera que se utilizara como reservas
o depósito de valor.
Ojo, eso no resolvería todos los problemas.
Habría que ver quien manda sobre esta divisa,
si se constituye un banco central supranacional,
si es factible poner de acuerdo a tantos países
con regímenes tan poco habituados a la transparencia
y a respetar las normas…
Pero es una posibilidad que está sobre la
mesa.
Y ni siquiera haría falta que derrotará
al dólar.
Perfectamente, podríamos estar ante el nacimiento
de un nuevo sistema monetario mucho más multipolar.
Al menos esta parece ser el objetivo de sus
promotores.
Pero…
¿Qué pasa con Estados Unidos?
¿Le preocupa este movimiento?
Pues…
Atentos.
T3(¿EL FIN DE LA HEGEMONÍA UNIPOLAR?)
Querida comunidad, es muy probable, sea la
moneda de los BRICS o cualquier otra, es muy
probable que antes o después el dólar sea
superado.
O, como mínimo, que encuentre un rival capaz
de hacerle sombra.
Es decir, que lo que una vez se calificó
como el “privilegio exorbitante” del dólar
llegará a su fin.
Y aún más, es muy posible que ese momento
no este demasiado lejos.
El empuje asiático ha hecho que la economía
de Estados Unidos cada vez tenga menos peso
en la economía mundial.
Del 40% del PIB global en los años 60 al
entorno del 24% hoy en día.
Y, ojo, que en términos monetarios el tamaño
es importante.
Y es que veréis, para que el dólar continúe
siendo la gran moneda de reserva, la economía
de Estados Unidos tiene que suministrarle
al resto del mundo cada vez más y más dólares
y, también, más y más activos nominados
en dólares.
Pues bien, esas son las operaciones que financian,
alimentan e, incluso, promueven la deuda del
gobierno federal y el déficit comercial crónico
que sufre el país.
Y aquí es donde hay una importante división
de opiniones.
Para unos Estados Unidos ha logrado hacer
de las finanzas un sector hiperproductivo
cuya producción casi que debería formar
parte de la balanza comercial.
Es decir, Estados Unidos exporta bienes, servicios
y, también, productos financieros.
Productos que a su vez han financiado el enorme
desarrollo tecnológico de este país.
¿Silicon Valley?
Pues eso.
Para otros, en cambio…
Todo esto en realidad podría ser una puñeta.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque la demanda mundial del dólar
hace que su valor sea más alto del que debería
ser, lo que castiga la producción local:
al encarecer los productos en dólares disminuye
la competitividad de su industria y reduce
los empleos industriales, que, además, suelen
estar muy bien pagados.
Eso es lo que defiende, por ejemplo, Jared
Bernstein.
¿Y quién es este tipo?
Pues ni más ni menos que el Jefe del Consejo
de Asesores Económicos de la Administración
Biden.
El economista jefe de la Casa Blanca [Vamos,
que no es un cualquiera]
Pues bien, según esta perspectiva…
El nacimiento de otra gran divisa no haría
temblar el poder del dólar - sobre todo en
términos absolutos - pero sí que permitiría
aliviar la fuerte presión que existe sobre
esta divisa.
De esta forma se podrían reducir algunos
grandes desequilibrios, como el déficit comercial
y se podría frenar la sobrevaloración relativa
que, según dicen tanto, está castigando
mucho la competitividad de las empresas industriales
de este país.
Pero, sea como sea, y estemos o no de acuerdo,
hay una cosa cierta: no todo el mundo está
tan contento con la hegemonía del dólar
a escala mundial.
En otras palabras, que quizás en Washington
no estén tan preocupados.
Por su enorme peso económico, por sus mercados
financieros y por la seguridad jurídica,
seguramente el dólar siga siendo una moneda
líder.
Pero, ¿Qué otra divisa que la acompañe?
Pues…
De entrada a la Administración Biden no parece
que esto sea algo les preocupe excesivamente…
Más bien, ya lo habéis visto, todo lo contrario.
La pregunta es: ¿Tienen razón?
¿Estados Unidos saldría ganando o perdiendo
con esta nueva moneda alternativa?
¿Realmente surgirá una divisa que sea capaz
de doblegar el poder del dólar?
¿Confiarías tus ahorros a una divisa liderada
por China y Rusia?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Recordad que con el código “POLITIK”
acabado en “K” podréis disfrutar de 3
meses extra totalmente gratis con Surfshark.
El link, como siempre, en la descripción.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.